[Music]
monday edition of pftot
the place where we address the things we
either didn't get to
or want to talk about in more detail
during the two hours that we had pft
live chris sims mike florio here with
you and let's continue the earl thomas
conversation chris
from the perspective of future options
we mentioned
on the way out on pft live that mike
mccarthy the cowboys coach speaking of
reporters today said that he's very
confident with
his roster here's the quote courtesy of
clarence hill of the fort worth star
telegram
we're very confident where we are as far
as the 80-man roster as far as any
prospect that's available
those are more conversations for jerry
jones stephen jones and will mcclay as
far as looking at that situation
i have nothing really to report so
the door's not shut right but mccarthy's
saying hey i'm fine with who i have
uh if you read between the lines you can
maybe see
mccarthy saying probably not
something we're looking for but again
it's it's above his pay grade literally
to make those decisions yeah
no it definitely is and we know they
have flirted with earl thomas in the
past before
earl thomas you know being a a texas
longhorn
i mean the two biggest entities in that
state are the texas longhorn and the
dallas cowboys
so i understand him wanting to go there
and all that
but you know as we talked about on the
show you know one
this is a cowboy team that's you know
got a lot of things to be happy about on
the roster
do we want to bring in uh you know an
an older star hall of fame type player
that's past his prime
that certainly seems to be somewhat of
an annoyance
in the last two locker rooms he was in
so do you want to deal with that and
then the big thing too is
you know chris richards not there
anymore or they're not running that
seattle defense
mike nolan's there so i don't know if
they fancy the type of player
that he is for that scheme and the fit
and all that like they used to
in the old days so it'll be interesting
i really am intrigued to see
who gets involved in this earl thomas
conversation
yeah and uh the atlanta falcons dan
quinn says no
and that's where we start pushing back
on this idea that
because somebody played with somebody
worked with somebody that means they're
gonna want to work together again well
no there's a chance that dan quinn looks
at and says
i've i've done my time with earl thomas
and if earl thomas isn't the player that
he was several years ago it's like the
antonio brown dynamic
you'll deal with the personality as long
as the player is off the charts great
exactly when the player
starts to dip we don't want to deal with
the person and for dan quinn to come out
today and say affirmatively no earl
thomas in atlanta they run that defense
for crying out loud
um that that's that's another
red flag to do your homework
talk to your friends tap your network
do your research and find out exactly
what went down with earl thomas in
seattle and baltimore before you go out
on a limb
well exactly right you know and and
again like
earl thomas amazing player hall of famer
i mean
you know a part of a special defense we
we talked about all that
but the simple reality of the situation
is right now
in this point of his career he's not as
good as ricardo allen
or kean o'neill he can't start over them
they're better than him
you know there's going to be a number of
teams where i think
you know the normal casual everyday fans
going to look at it and go why wouldn't
we want earl thomas why wouldn't we
honor old thomas because he's still a a
big name
and flashing lights and we he's a
household name
but but the reality to me and
again you know i'm ron jaworski and i
watched the film and all that crap
you know yeah we're talking about a
middle of the pack and i mean
not like on the edge of like ooh that
you know he's just in the middle of the
pack just on the edge of the cream of
the crop
no no he is severely entrenched in the
middle of the pack
maybe in the back end of the middle of
the pack where he is at this part of his
career
so that's where i just think it's going
to be hard too between the attitude the
play
you know what kind of prices he can
demand all of those things i think are
going to make teams question it a little
bit
unless you feel bad for earl thomas he
got 20 million dollars from the ravens
for one year
with the team and he has at least an
effort a claim a possibility of another
10 million
depending upon how the inevitable
grievance unfolds between
the ravens and the national football
league players association all right
there was a grievance filed by colin
kaepernick a couple of years ago against
the nfl for colluding to keep him
out it's all well documented we know the
story by now it was actually
four years ago thursday
that colin kaepernick was first noticed
not standing
for the national anthem prior to a
preseason game he didn't stand for the
first two but he wasn't in uniform it
was the third preseason game
august 27 2016. he was in uniform you
could see the name emblazoned across the
back of the jersey that's when the
issue began and here we are still
talking about it we're talking about
today not because we're just looking for
something to talk about
we're talking about it chris because the
commissioner
was a guest on emmanuel acho's very
excellent digital series uncomfortable
conversations with a black man
right and the question came up and and
acho asked him point blank
what would you say by way of apology or
expression of remorse
to colin kaepernick here's what godel
said the first thing i'd say
is i'd wish we had listened earlier
cap to what you were kneeling about and
what you were trying to bring
attention to he immediately follows it
with this we had invited him in several
times to have the conversation have the
dialogue i wish we had the benefit of
that we never did
and you know we would have benefited
from it absolutely there's a pivot there
it's a subtle pivot to throw blame on
colin kaepernick for never
accepting their invitation to come in
and talk well here's the thing here's
the thing
let's go back to august of 2016. after
this happened on a friday night
it was a sunday morning that colin
kaepernick met with the media and
explained
why he was doing what he was doing he
explained it
exactly the way that he always has
it's because of police brutality it's
because you get a license to carry
lethal force in your hand with half of
the training that's required
to carry a curling iron in your hand at
least in california that was the case at
the time yes
so he made it clear what more did anyone
need to hear
it's that they didn't want to hear it's
that we reject your premise
it's that anything other than standing
at attention during the national anthem
is disrespect to the flag the military
in the country
and we don't care what your explanation
is so
nothing he would have said in august of
2016 if he had gone straight to 345 park
avenue would have made a damn bit of
difference so
that that we need to put that in context
that they didn't
this isn't some secret code that needs
to be revealed
in a closed-door meeting he said
publicly
august 29 2016 exactly why he was doing
what
he was doing and that's why after george
floyd was killed so many of us were like
yeah kaepernick told us about this four
years ago right well yeah
i mean the nfl dropped the ball there's
no other way to really
you know skirt around this they messed
up
they should have confronted this head-on
the first time around
you know and then of course they bowed
to the political pressures
uh at that moment and you know quite
honestly
it didn't seem like our society was in
the same place to be as accepting as it
is right now
i mean unfortunately it took lots and
lots of
unarmed black people to be shot dead for
like
you know misdemeanors and and things
that they had no
not you know nothing should never be
shot or anything like that
and and now now there's remorse and it's
opened
the eyes of america and a lot of people
now i would still say there's a lot of
crazy crap going on there right now but
yeah the nfl they did them dirty there's
no doubt about it
and i i really did think that they were
gonna try to
find a way to get them on a team or a
roster here
by this time just you know in some
capacity especially with the rules being
different this year
and the extra people on the practice
squads and all that
but i still think it's showing you these
teams are scared to do it
they're still scared of the backlash
they're gonna get
you know racism still going and it's
still thriving here in america i mean
i'm not so sure it hasn't gotten worse
here
the last few weeks so it's driving me
crazy
and of course because of that teams they
want money and don't want to deal with
the controversy
and i'm sure they're chickening out when
it comes to this type of
conversation with colin kaepernick that
excellent video that was ultimately
produced by an nfl employee who went
rogue with all the players one after
another saying what they want from the
league
when the commissioner matched that the
next day and he was praised for it and
rightfully so it was the most they've
ever done
to acknowledge that they were wrong
about anything really ever
but the players wanted a specific
acknowledgement of kaepernick the video
from roger goodell did not
include it and you know even with that
a sense developed in june that hey you
know what
i can't believe it he's actually going
to end up on a team
and then i got the sense chris and we've
talked about it before on the show
that they were just running out the
clock yeah let's just let's just make it
look like it's going to happen
until the world moves on to something
else because it always does
and we no longer have this unrelenting
pressure to give colin kaepernick a job
and here we are
two and a half months later from
memorial day to the brink of labor day
and it hasn't happened and as you said
it's a different kind of a year and you
can have four guys on your practice
squad
four guys who have unlimited nfl
experience now
and and and there's urgency to have
quarterbacks available and healthy and
ready to go so
i i'm gonna say what i've said all along
the commissioner can make this happen if
he wants to he has the power to get
colin kaepernick
on a team there are ways to do it if you
really want to do it
there are favors that can be traded
there are promises that can be made
this is how business gets done whether
it's
private organization public organization
this is how it happens if you truly want
something if you
want it and you're the commissioner if
you're the guy in charge
there's a way to make it happen the
question is do you really want it
and until colin kaepernick's on a roster
anything the commissioner or anyone else
says about him is just noise it's
meaningless
it's not a real apology it's a hollow
apology it's an incomplete apology until
he's back on a roster and if he wanted
it to happen the commissioner could make
it happen and until it happens
it's just talk chris it's and now we
have to talk about it yeah it would be
it would be neglectful for us to not
mention it because it's the commissioner
on the record answering the tough
question
i just i just don't accept it as an
apology per se
until the situation giving rise to the
apology is rectified
get him back on a team yeah i i mean i
hear you you know it and
it like i hear you with the commissioner
thing too but i also want to be like
well you know
the 32 owners need to get behind it too
and
you know pressure the commissioner to
keep this on his radar and think about
it and go hey this is what we need for
the sport
but i you know i doubt that's happening
i don't know i don't seem to hear any
clamoring that way
and it's unfortunate uh because yes
colin kaepernick
he he sacrificed some great physical
ability
for a greater good and now we see that
he was right
and nothing's being done about it and
that's thanks and then this is it
like this is it like you know you and i
thought there might be a chance he'd get
on a team this year
and this was dicey to begin with let
alone how long it's been since he played
football
he's not on a team here in the next week
or two
it's over forever at least in my book i
mean just and i'm not trying to say that
to be insensitive but just
you know what i'm saying through the nfl
coach's eyes and the gms
they're going to go well this is four
years he hasn't played quarterback in
four years
and that'll be and that'll be the end of
his career
the ability to delay this makes
the ability to keep delaying it even
stronger and
you know last year week two thursday
night cam newton
foot injury ends up done for the year
ben roethlisberger sunday
seahawks elbow goes done for the year
drew brees hits his hand on
on aaron donald he's out for six weeks
although they had their backup plan in
place but between the steelers and the
panthers
you know and something like that here's
the thing
maybe it's all dormant for now and maybe
what the commissioner said last night
won't
won't kick it up again and maybe the
incident that happened in wisconsin
yesterday won't kick it up again but
maybe it will
if a quarterback goes down with a
serious injury in september
i think it's gonna be a lot harder this
year to justify not bringing colin
kaepernick in
and giving him a fair opportunity to
make the team although what we'll hear
is what we heard last year next man up
our roster's ready the guy knows our
offense we don't want to bring in a
stranger
all the excuses that have been used over
and over again are going to be trotted
out again chris
and uh i i you know before george floyd
i said this is done this is over
kaepernick's never playing in the nfl
i had a three or four week period after
george floyd where i thought hey you
know this has a chance
but you know i i started hearing i
started talking to people hey is anybody
reaching out no
remember that report from nfl media
they're talking to friends and
associates
of colin kaepernick talk to him yeah
talk to him talk to his agent
it's it's like he's radioactive and no
one's going to touch him with a 40-foot
pole
so i i just i think that uh you know
they can talk all they want
but i'd be stunned at this point if he
ends up back in the league
no i would too and and you know just
with this yeah the covert 19
offseason things like that coaches got
their hands full
right now they've already started to
formulate their teams and figured out
finally the process in which to go about
training camp in this new day and age on
a day-to-day basis and all that
and yeah most of them aren't going to
want to deal with the curveball of
you know colin kaepernick and the added
you know attention of all that
whether it's right or wrong you know i
do think there is that aspect too
and uh yeah i just i think the the ship
for colin kaepernick has probably sailed
as far as nfl football is concerned
one last thing before we go as react in
real time to the developments that are
happening while we're discussing other
things
bio reference laboratories issuing a
statement monday morning to explain
what resulted in 77 false positives for
11 different teams
over the weekend here's the statement
chris on august 22
bioreference laboratories reported an
elevated number of positive covet 19
pcr test results for nfl players and
personnel
at multiple clubs the nfl immediately
took necessary actions to ensure the
safety of the players
and personnel our investigation
indicated that these were most likely
false positive results
caused by an isolated contamination
during test preparation in the new
jersey
laboratory reagents analyzers and staff
were all ruled out as possible causes
and
subsequent testing has indicated that
the issue has been resolved
all individuals impacted have been
confirmed
negative and informed that's the
statement from john r
cohen executive chairman of bioreference
laboratories
boiling that down to english and i'm
going to apologize in advance
sorry mom they'll bleep me they're
taping this
those words that i just read can be
explained as
happens that's the official explanation
from bioreference laboratory sometimes
it happens
and happened and that's all we can tell
you we don't know how it happened
we don't know why it happened but hey it
happens
that's the that's not very comforting as
it relates to 256 regular season games
and 13 postseason games
the possibility of [ __ ] happening again
sorry to kristen coleman in advance who
has to
edit all of my various profanity but
it's the perfect explanation
for what they're saying it is and man
you said it three times wow it's
impressive right there um
yeah i i mean you're right i don't know
what that means either contamination i
mean what i don't know
either way but either way you know to to
uh echo your sentiments that better not
happen once we start regular season
football
because it's going to mess up a lot of
people's lives and
ours included so hopefully they can get
some of these kinks worked out whatever
that is
and maybe we'll hear a little bit more
transparency as far as
what exactly you know isolated
contamination means
i mean i'm sorry bioreference
laboratories but i dealt with this kind
of corporate double speak for years when
i was practicing law you have found a
way to piece together
300 words 200 words whatever it is
and and it says nothing yeah it says
nothing isolated
contamination but they they have ruled
out reagents analyzers
and staff well what what the hell
happened did a bird fly in the window
i mean how how do you did you spill
like a positive coven 19 test on the 77
other tests i don't understand that
either and that's the thing how does the
contamination
occur does it occur spontaneously
somebody had to have done it
it's not like somebody's walking by with
a box full of covid19 that falls onto
the test samples there's got to be a
better explanation this i reject this
explanation
and i reject it because until they know
exactly what happened
and until they know how to keep it from
happening again we're going to have to
deal with this
every day there's an nfl game or every
day there isn't
the constant possibility that there's
going to be this huge
uptick in positives that may derail a
game
derail a team set a roster back 10 guys
and then they're going to have to make
tough decisions about what to do all
because
it happened in one of the five
bioreference laboratories yeah well
and you know to add to that in a year
where like
practice is at a premium right now
coaches are feeling the pressure
they're under a time crunch i mean it
was just a few days ago their guys were
running wind sprints now we're
we're going holy crap we got to get
ready for a game here coming around the
you know around the corner
so to lose a day a practice like some
teams did yesterday
or have the wrench thrown into their
plans man you know
just another thing to deal with with
some of these football teams where it's
hard enough as is to get ready for week
one so
um yeah i don't know mike you're right i
mean it was a lot of nonsense in that
and that uh
little comment there well let's just
hope that
whatever the truth is they know it and
they've chosen to conceal it as opposed
to we don't know what happened
right let's hope they know and let's
hope they're not conceived they're not
revealing it and that they
fix it i'll be fine with it if it ends
up being fixed this just doesn't inspire
a whole lot of confidence in me
that we're not going to have a situation
like this pop up on a sunday
between week 1 week 17 or
wild card round or division round or
championship round or super bowl sunday
could you imagine
could you imagine something like that
happening so hopefully they know
hopefully they'll have a plan and
hopefully this won't happen again what
will happen again
is pft live every weekday morning until
they tell us to stop
pft ot on the days we have other things
to talk about chris sims has plenty of
things to talk about later today on
chris sims unbuttoned
check out profootballtalk.com all day
long everybody have a great day thanks
for joining us we'll see you tuesday see
[Music]
ya
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports